grab that aspirin because we've got
another debate hangover Donald Trump and
three other guys took the stage in Miami
last night before Super Tuesday part 3
happens on March fifteenth if you are
looking for another cage match well
we're sorry to tell you what we got was
substance on issues like education
social security and foreign policy
here's what happened in 90 seconds we
finally got into the nitty-gritty on
trade which is Trump central and
distinguishing policy issue trade deals
are absolutely killing our country if
you don't tax certain products coming
into this country from certain countries
we're going to continue to lose
businesses and we're going to continue
to lose jobs yes Trump wants to protect
American jobs by enacting higher tariffs
the forty five percent tax is a threat
it's not a tax it was a threat but the
other candidates pushed back on Trump's
protectionism it's not China that pays
the tax it's you the working men and
women we've seen prior presidential
candidates who proposed massive tariffs
you know smoot-hawley led to the Great
Depression score one for Cruz on getting
a smoot-hawley reference in but what
about outsourcing I know the h-1b very
well and it's something that I frankly
use and I shouldn't be allowed to use we
shouldn't have it while Trump wants a
pause on worker visas that he himself
uses Rubio wants to close loopholes for
companies abusing the program the visa
should only be available for companies
to use directly to hire workers and that
we should be stricter and how we enforce
it so rubio thinks politicians in
Washington are better at making a hiring
decisions than the businesses who are
actually hiring okay what are the
candidates think about Cuba I would
probably have the embassy closed until
such time as a really good deal was made
a 50-plus year embargo on Cuba has done
nothing but the GOP field wants to keep
the failed policy why not let Americans
see the horrors of socialism firsthand
oh and when it comes to foreign policy
and all the candidates still want to
bomb the hell out of the Middle East
it's got to be shock-and-awe in the mill
in the military speak but other than
that it was a pretty civil evening am i
right I cannot believe how civil it's
been up here and that's what we got from
the Republican debate